Hello everyone, Ace Combat series brand producer
is over there. Today, we will deliver a new play video of Ace Combat 7 that is under development for gamescom held in Germany.
Introducing 5 minutes Of
course, you can take a closer look at the expectations in the hanger mode
. You can also take a closer look at the characteristic delta wings.
Typhoon is a multi-roll key, but this time I would like to choose a long-range air-to-air missile
.
[Music]
berobeiman
Then
, I'm going to sortie. Yes, I think you can see this, but
today's stage is different from e 3 and it
's a line.
It smells
more and more If you fight in this place today, it will not be with Jim. The
aircraft should not vibrate.
Someone who is throwing heavy rain
is said to be blown up by the updraft like this in 7 this time.
The example of a cloud is a beautiful blue sky, but the star is a ridiculous dive. It is said that
this situation creates a chest
. It will be a review of how to play Ace Combat.
It's a game to shoot down
Becky, aiming at
Becky and getting sick again
.  There is also
a person who is doing Sumita for the first time. Regards, I
will do the picture. Even when I aim, there
are enemies in the distance, so
I would like to use it for a short distance 3 years older.
Io
was conspicuous over a long distance, but
I wonder if he was happy. I
was switching the site special face-on in line with last year's election.
That will be strategically important.
I hate chasing and go into the clouds As
I introduced last time, in this situation I hardly put it in front,
right? There is an enemy in the lower right
.
Story
Kicker role Anzu I especially thought
Ah ah ah
I'm pairing behind this
I'm going to end up from the pecking period behind
me. I'm sirocco, I'm hungry.
I can't hit it right now. Now I'm tying my
tongue with disinfecting my teeth.
When I get into the
picture, I look at the station at the time, and when I'm
worried about the plate for a moment, I can't see it anymore, so
I don't have the intention of the map creator.
Yes,
I won.
Wasn't it the city in front of you? I
'll finish it quickly.
Ah ah ah, did you
buy a pit cake for a moment? You can cross-pet over there.
It's a bald person who approaches to, and the place where it shines is very big. Defeat the
enemy.
If possible, everyone is in plain hot water.
I brought it
teraterm
none
ware At the
end
I feel like a parar pickle fork rope Because it is a mime car,
I will introduce it 40 times and then the door
Who will come out?
I would like to finish this video in this area.
Thank you. I was Kono, the brand producer of the Ace Combat series
.